I've always had that inner fire in me
like I gotta prove him wrong you know
that comes from I think my hip-hop
spirit a little bit I'm not gonna wait
for that mic to be passed to me I have
to like grab it my name is Jonathan park
also known as dumbfounded a rapper based
out of Los Angeles California I grew up
in front of the television you know my
whole personality is based off of like
sitcoms from the 90s you know I started
having interests in entertainment it
started getting a little discouraging
cuz I wouldn't see anybody on television
or films that look like me and that's
when I started to be going a little bit
more aggressive with everything I do
yeah daddy was G granddaddy wasn't G to
faint at the bank when I started hopping
on stages when I got a microphone I
wanted to be loud and I wanted to be
heard and I wanted to be outlandish and
say crazy stuff you know and that's kind
of what built this confidence in me to
pursue rat and rap the things that I
want to talk about yeah
took me Asay the song in music video
safe is pretty much my response to the
whitewashing of Asians in Hollywood or
any minority in the entertainment
industry and I wanted to kind of come at
it aggressively on the song that now we
aren't you know the model minority we
have things to say and you're going to
hear a rebuttal if you attack us growing
up with a very traditional Korean
American family in the household being
involved in music and arts that was a
rare thing at the time for Asian parents
to accept
when they turned on the television saw
no Asians on TV door like there's no
money in this you know what I mean
but growing up in Koreatown gave me tons
of confidence confidence of Who I am as
a person being a strong Korean American
without feeling like an outsider and
that's a responsibility on its own to
take that influence around me and
translate it into my art and share these
stories of my people all across you know
you